That's all we're going to talk
about in terms of HMMs in gesture.
I'll say the good things about it were,
it was a learning paradigm, right.
So, you define some features, by the way
you have to define the right features,
you collect some well-annotated data,
which also takes some work.
But given that, you're able to train
your HMMs by just giving it the data.
So it's a learning paradigm and
that's good.
The training is a little bit slow,
it's not very slow.
But recognition can be very
fast because of that recursive
those recursive algorithms
we talked about.
Running those is very quick.
So, so that works really well.
You know, of course,
not everything is perfect.
They're not as good for segmentation
labeling as some newer methods.
I mentioned conditional
random fields earlier.
If you actually have something
where your training data
has particular underlying states and
you know what those states are.
So it's not even really
a hidden marker model.
It is a, It is a marker model, but
your training data you know
the underlying states.
And you're seeing an observation and
you want that state sequence for, for
that segmentation,
there are now better methods and
I mentioned in
conditioned random fields.
You know, in general,
this stuff requires a reasonable
amount of data to train one
of the reasons it was used for speech is
we have lots and lots and lots of data.
Although I will say that HMMs may
require less data than some of these
more discriminative methods.
And then I put down something
that I think is tonalogical,
but also important to know.
I said it works well
when the problem is easy.
We did a lot of work on HMMs,
gesture, etc., whatever.
And it's very powerful for
capturing regularities,
when the regularities are quite clear.
You have to do a lot more work
on your feature selection and
a bunch of other things when those
differences are a little bit harder to,
to see number of states and
those kind of things.
So you know that, and that's probably
true of most classification methods.
When the problem is easy,
they all work great.
It's when the problem is not so
easy that, that the challenge comes in.
And that's when people start
reporting on small differences.
That means the real issue in def,
in choosing your classifiers
to understand where the complexity and
where the difficulty of your problem is.
But in general, people still use
HMMs a lot, and they use it for
describing activity or,
or, or time series.
And you know, it's, in some sense,
your first line of defense
against activity recognition.